all right let's talk about the Dilbert
Scott Adams Fiasco uh so some of you may
recall that Scott Adams the guy who
draws the Dilbert cartoon has been on
this program before and we used to kind
of mix it up on Twitter and then a few
years ago I think it was kind of
earlyish in the pandemic he just blocked
me on Twitter and I know that I could
like log out to see what he's posting
but I don't care that much so I've not
been following Scott Adams since he cut
me off and when he would be on we would
have like spirited discussions which I
thought were generally pretty good but
something kind of started to go wrong
with Scott Adams and when he banned me a
black band me when he blocked me from
Twitter
he really seemed to almost like crack
like it was I don't remember what it was
over but he I think I said oh I think
that you're arguing in bad faith about
something and he went crazy insulted me
and then blocked me and and just seems
to kind of descend it into a dark place
over the last several years
I found out over the weekend that he
Unleashed a completely racist meltdown
style tirade on Twitter and that this
subsequently led to a bunch of
newspapers saying yeah we're gonna get
rid of Dilbert we're all set with
Dilbert we're not going to have it
anymore now I I admit personally
it really bums me out I used to love
Dilbert growing up and I know a lot of
people like oh Dilbert's so lame it's
boring whatever I really liked it
growing up and it was just kind of a sad
thing to see Scott Adams descend into
such political insanity and now even
beyond that where I don't know this
seems to be going beyond the political
to the personal something really seems
to be going on but fear not he has some
Defenders Elon Musk has come out of the
woodwork to defend Scott Adams so let's
look at what's going on CNN article from
this morning says Elon Musk defended
Dilbert Creator Scott Adams after
hundreds of newspapers stopped printing
the comic strip because of Adam's recent
racist comments last week Adams called
Black Americans a hate group and
suggested white people should quote get
the hell away from them oof Adams
effectively encouraged segregation in a
shocking rant on his YouTube channel his
comments came in response to a poll from
the conservative firm Rasmussen reports
not a good pollster by the way that said
53 percent of black Americans agree with
the statement it's okay to be white
in response to a tweet twitter owner
musk said Sunday that quote the media is
racist
you know it's so funny the Wright loves
to say you got to be really careful when
you call someone racist that's one of
the most serious things you can do how
can you call Scott Adams racist when you
don't know what's in his head and
regardless of what he said he might not
really be racist in all these things oh
oh Elon Musk is defending him the media
is racist yep check us out no no
critique needed there
um musk also didn't criticize Scott
Adams comments and musk said without
evidence that quote for a very long time
the U.S media was racist against
non-white people now they're racist
against whites and Asians
same thing happened with Elite colleges
and high schools in America maybe they
can try not being racist musk later
agreed with a tweet saying Adam's
comments weren't good but had an element
of Truth
he accused the media of giving black
victims of police violence
disproportionate coverage over white
black people are more likely to die from
Police use of force than white people
according to multiple studies
what were Adam's comments well here they
are
um he said on his YouTube show quote if
nearly half of all blacks are not okay
with white people according to this poll
not according to me that's a hate group
I don't want to have anything to do with
them and I would say based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
to get the hell away from black people
just get the F away because there's no
fixing this he has since said on Twitter
he was only advising people to avoid
hate so anyway we now have all these
articles about how newspapers are
dropping the comic strip and of course
all of these right-wingers are saying
this is now censorship
some newspapers said it's not a
difficult decision the Cleveland Plains
dealer said we are dropping the Dilbert
comic strip because of Scott Adams
racist rant USA today's Network also
dropped it so listen it's all the exact
same stuff that we always hear and it's
the same routine Scott Adams in response
to this tweeted quote Dilbert has been
canceled from all new newspapers
websites calendars and books because I
gave some advice everyone agreed with
wow my syndication partner canceled me
so listen I think something is is very I
think Scott Adams is struggling
personally but that doesn't mean we
excuse the things he said everybody here
is exercising their rights Scott Adams
expressed his speech in this insane
tirade on YouTube which he followed up
on Twitter
people who read it responded and said I
either like that or I don't and some of
them stopped following Scott Adams and
some of them said I'm not going to read
the Dilbert strip anymore and some of
them wrote to newspapers and said don't
carry this anymore everybody is speaking
this is speech and then newspapers made
a decision with whatever barometer they
want to use to make that decision some
said we're no longer going to carry the
comic strip everybody is expressing
their rights it's the free market at
work it's action and reaction remember
we're not talking about the First
Amendment because this is not about the
government doing anything but we are
talking here about everybody's rights to
say what they want and sometimes things
you say have consequences a lot of
people struggle or are unwilling to
accept
that quote free speech sometimes used
colloquially doesn't mean my speech
can't have consequences or therefore it
is no longer free speech and of course
good thing Elon Musk showed up and
cleared it up by reminding us the media
is racist which really added significant
moral clarity as you can imagine so
let's
everybody here has been allowed to say
whatever they want you don't have a
right to have a syndicated
um comic strip if Scott Adams wants to
take control back he can keep drawing
Dilbert and just release it on his
website he would then control the
platform nobody would be able to quote
cancel him and that's absolutely
something that he can do but it's
seeming like a sort of sad
I don't want to call it the end for
Scott Adams but it's been a very sad
decline particularly for me because I
really used to like the comic script
when I was you know 12 years old I I
thought it was good